seam pass from Seth Jones to Jason Dickinson
but now a chance for the St Louis Blues and a
big save by Peter moric right there and here's
the play Here by neighbors neighbors trying to
slide that underneath morazzi Bella is going
to cover a lot of real estate in front of that
net on the PK and whistle shoot save Bennington
he pushes the puck away make a statement Thomas
is going to go off for a slashing call and
there was the Chance by an whistle a really
good scoring chance right there as he gets
his stick on then slides it right between
the legs then the r shot trying to go high
to the glove sight Jones back to kurashev
Tyler Johnson with his heels in the crease
radish for Johnson and the puck scooped up
by Bennington boiler tapped in gathers his Puck
boy that's a way to pass it to yourself smart
Play here's zeit out the defenseman scores
Nikita zev's second goal of the season and
the Blackhawks take a one- nothing lead oh
that's a big plus getting a goal from a defense
he's got two of them Kevin kinsky not playing
in tonight's game has the other one and a good
play by vasic on the left side though that pinch
made this possible Gutman got the puck plays it
right over and it's a perfect feed over to zitb
who reads it and he goes against the grain that
I think that hit somebody before it went in the
net yes it did hit the left shoulder of the
defenseman Scott perunovich done a good job
establishing leads on this homeand they were
able to keep it a one- nothing lead all the
way home two nights ago against Anaheim to the
line kept in by Jason Dickinson Dickinson to the
crease save Bennington rebound trickles out to
Shen and a hard for check by Dickinson back to
Center he is all over the place Felino right
back to work second of the season Seth Jones
Jason Dickinson a very energized start Isaac
Phillips off the post whoa Thomas to the loose
Puck swallowed up by vasic but the puck still
in St Louis control Nick ly to the net and mazic
found the rebound reel turns couldn't quite get a
shot away but now he might redirected and whistle
after the loose Puck hardworking shift for this
fourth line for the Hawks classic fires scores
it's a two nothing lead for the Hawks and yes
you're right without denado these three are are
charged up and this play here just D to D simple
there's some traffic in front a little bit of a
moving screen I think blasic originally thought
that reel might have tipped it but that's not
the case whatsoever it didn't hit anybody
with just a moving screen that's tough to
follow from a golender point of view and this
Puck had eyes it's always generated the chances
so this is a great bonus here to begin this
game Anthony boiler knocked Away by Jordan
Bennington Ander you need your forwards to play
defense too goes both ways called being connected
need five players on the ice well connected
that's how this start of the game has gone
and it's the exact remedy going up against a team
that that lost 5-2 last night in Columbus there's
a blocker saved by on a shot from Justin faul
Robert Thomas a two goal Knight last night in
Columbus neighbors couldn't get the feed Faulk
Sav moric rebound loose Zev pushes down push
navic shoulders neighbors and now a battle for
the puck Murphy tries to keep po navette Bay but
Thomas nearly wins the puck for St Louis Dickinson
after bumping neighbors battling Thomas again and
Felino at Center ice over the line f looking for
Dickinson and it finds Bennington instead got a
helper in this game as well Tyler Johnson off
the draw to the net kicked away Bennington Cole
Gutman Johnson for Gutman Cole Gutman wide ice
Taylor radish off the post Seth Jones Taps it
back radish his way right there yeah sh here's
a two-on-one break and you see Gutman waits
for Krug to come towards him and as he does so
he waits and waits and waits and once he does
that pass is going to go through the seam and
radish got the wide open net right here oh my
goodness second meeting of the Season between
the blues and the Blackhawks Blues were here
two weeks ago 14 to2 and Tyler Johnson snaps
one off into the glove of Jordan Bennington
classic intercepted and Robert Thomas trying to
get something going for the blues Thomas has got
the hot hand barzik makes the save the puck
was loose consecutive games without a match
a that's a whole heck of a lot he always
reminds me when I see him Glenn does that
don't forget the playoff games Darren yeah
that's true an extra 58 or something like
that incredible number incredible man wasn't an 82
game regular season schedule either Conor Murphy
lest defenseman trying to join the rush for the
Hawks Johnson for radish pass Murphy this line
is really buzzed for the Hawks Cole Gutman in
the crease stopped by Bennington Seth Jones as
mcin gets tripped up on the back of the apron
but here's sunquist again in front knocked Away
by morazzi and Seth Jones and BR Stripped by
Lucas Reichel Reel with a good for check and
Reese Johnson with the shot rebound stopped
by Bennington got a they're both sasky boys
so we're still five on five with the fighting
Majors Nikita Zev opened the scoring
for the Blackhawks 113 to go in the
first this should be booted out of that face
off no they're not doing it and whistle and
Hayes allowed to fight for the puck and
zitek tees up Conor Murphy right into
Bennington Robert Thomas behind the net P
navic perunovic Paro save morazzi Anderson
to the loose Puck Puck kicked by boiler
Seth Jones reaches for it kyou throws it
toward the net and into the glove of mazic
Debut season in the National Hockey League
Casper capping in that was off Cole Gutman
down low for Tyler Johnson Taylor radish and
Cole Gutman and whistle with a big time crunch
on BR nvic Faulk drives one save moric rebound
to the Hawks Murphy holds the Zone Murphy for
Felino line change for the Hawks turning up
the heat on St Louis Zev towards the Net score
Jason Dickinson on the back door three nothing
Blackhawks well executed in the offensive zone
and you get some fresh bodies on the ice there
on the right side of your screen poino jumps
onto the ice and now keep your eye on this play
by zitp as he goes back door to the far post and
end and the St Louis Blues are all Puck watching
right there and that is a perfectly executed pass
beyond the Stick of sun twist Beyond The Stick
of faul and Dickinson keeps his concentration an
eye on the puck and his strong lower hand on the
left and as radish to his left he plays it to Bard
Bard Johnson for kurf what a save by the glove of
Bennington vasic Bard over to Seth
Jones Jones to the net blocked by Ley
Jones fights for the rebound but Ley up Bice
with Alexi tchenko to the trailing sunquist
score Oscar sunquist gets St Louis on the board
with 329 to play seventh short-handed goal this
year and the two-on-one break in the the trailer
for The three-on-one Break is Sunquest and he has
had four or five good chances in this game and
this one he just rifles the Joey Anderson out to
Center two in a row for the
Hawks they beat St Louis 3 to one